we have a very serious problem right now
and i'm going to
uh offend youtube's delicate
sensibilities but whatever
tim don't do that from pink news dot co
dot uk they say majority who oppose
trans rights and black lives matter
movement have warped sense of reality
according to science
oh science it's not according to science
that's hilarious
the first the first lie i mean the title
itself is a lie but it's not a
coordinating science it was just a
survey what they did was they asked
people whether they supported
trans rights or black lives matter then
they asked them basic fact
basic fact questions they found that
those
who dis who did not support these
movements had a
incorrectly answered the basic fact
questions about
crime statistics and things like that
okay that's not
that's not i would argue that's not
necessarily science to do a survey and
asking the questions
but the more importantly the reason is
you
thinking that cnn is real facts it could
be that you
have the warped sense of reality and
because you believe crackpot bs you
think
they have a warped sense of reality
therein lies the big conundrum
but hey guess what i can actually break
it down one step further for you and
show us the the extent of this true
problem please
zach goldberg tweeted this april 11th
2020.
in this image has a doctor or other
healthcare provider ever told you that
you have a mental health condition
the percent of very conservatives who
who said
yes they had a mental health condition
what do you think the number is how many
very conservatives non-white and white
answered yes to having a mental health
condition i know that it is lower than
the number of people on the left who
answered yes i guarantee it is
14.8 for non-white and white among
conservative just regular conservatives
11.2 percent of concern white
conservatives
say that they have been told by a doctor
they have a mental health condition
very liberal white people 38 percent
uh white liberals 26
white moderates 19.5 holy moly now some
argue it's because
liberals are more likely to go to the
doctor in the first place why
because they have issues boom exactly
exactly but they'll say like well no
it's because they all have issues but
only liberals are willing to accept them
and it's like
no only liberals are willing to force
you to accept their issues
so here's the problem they create
articles where they say you're crazy
you're the crazy one
believe what what cnn says or you're
wrong and you have a warped as a reality
you know the differences between boys
and girls you're insane
you see what i tweeted something's wrong
with your mind i tweeted a screenshot
from the wikipedia page for a woman yeah
yes and it says i
responded very indignant and someone
called me a fascist it's like
i didn't even comment on it i just took
a screenshot of it
for all you know i was critical of it
nope they were like there's fascism
anyway well timothy let me just make it
break it down
here's what's happening in this country
it's not left versus right it's not
authoritarian versus libertarian it's
not nationals versus a globalist
it's healthy and mentally ill
you think i'm kidding i've got the data
right here show the data again put it up
let's apply pl play a game there you go
take it up with zach goldberg
pew american trends panel the further
left you go
the more instances you find of mental
illness now
the left might say but you're missing a
context oh well we're not going to make
assumptions about what the study says
like your pink news study just says that
people who don't support your movement
have a weapons of reality
okay they're also less likely to be
mentally ill in the first place well
it's so ironic because all they do is
project dissent has been utterly
pathologized by these by these people if
you don't agree with them you are
transphobic homophobic islamophobe you
have some kind of phobia there's
something wrong with your brain you
suffer from a mental illness because you
don't bend the knee
i'm going to tell people they're freedom
phobic freedom phobic
that's kind of goldfish yeah there's
something wrong with your head was there
a word for like
fear of independence i'm sure probably
well
fear of personal responsibility it's
already progressive
we're already there tim i can't believe
you said you're such a fascist an adult
human
female is a woman a woman is an adult
human and that's actually so
the the foundational thinkers of fascism
said that like that's what mussolini
said
fascism is saying boys and girls are
different and the more different boys
and girls are the fascist you're it is
somebody somebody was like
just like tim poole not to show you the
full context
and then took a screenshot of under it
where it says a trans woman
is a person assigned male at birth
identifies as female and then i
responded i was like are you saying
trans women aren't women
like because he took an entirely
separate segment that said trans women i
mean i'm saying that
the point is when the left comes out and
says trans women are women
it creates a a a a a a recursive loop on
wikipedia yep
so if you go to woman and it's adult
human female
and then you go to trans woman and it
says a trans woman is a woman and you
click woman it says an adult human
female
they they contradict each other so i'm
not i'm not saying this as judgment or
or in any way disrespect anybody i'm
just saying
it is a recursive loop on wikipedia
where they just refer to each other with
no clear definition
yeah the system can't support itself man
if there's no logic
and there's no uh structure by which we
understand information
eventually people just stare at the wall
confused well that's exactly and this is
why i've said many times that
progressivism
is just a word we give to social decay
all that they can do is deconstruct so
they'll look at how male and female are
defined
and they'll attempt to pick that apart
by finding some finding some exception
to the rule
or saying this person doesn't feel as if
they fit in with your definition
subjectively
but when you ask them to define what a
woman is they do not have a definition
it's
someone feels like a woman okay what
does that mean someone tried today i
went it kind of went viral
they were like you still haven't defined
woman and the person said
well it's the person who takes the
stereotypical
passive role in reproductive acts or
something like that
and it's like it's a really bad
definition that's not definition at all
they're a bunch of guys who like
doing submissive stuff or whatever or
whatever there are a bunch of women who
like abuse dudes
does that define them as female oh this
is crazy though i just got this idea tim
what if because sex is named after
literal sexual intercourse we divided
people on the basis of the role they
play in that act and whether they can be
impregnated or impregnate somebody
well it's that well see the problem is
it's like uh
that cartoon you made about gender not
existing because some people fall
outside of the
typical definition like those people
don't create a new role
right right like a post-menopausal woman
they say oh well you know some women
can't have kids because they're
postmenopausal are they not women
anymore and it's like dude
we should we should like i'm sorry go
ahead finish your thoughts no it's just
like it's
all they're doing is arguing semantics
we should divulge more into how
crazy people are because we could just
say they're crazy but i think
understanding why they're crazy is also
going to be very important here because
if you look at
fluoride okay alex jones i have a theory
i actually really want to get into this
okay okay i really want to talk about
this because i think it's worth
mentioning because a lot of people fall
for these traps they don't know that
they're falling for it and a lot of them
are victims of it
and don't even realize it but a lot of
people who are
mentally ill are usually in a constant
fear state because of the mainstream
media
their diet literally alters their brain
chemistry especially with
sugars and processed chemical chemicals
a lot of the work that people do is
sedentary they don't work they don't
exercise
a lot of social media feeds on the ego
feeds on the narcissism
a lot of the people stay out of nature
and they're not harmoniously
physically uh you know together they're
they're
on top of each other literally bumping
into each other going
crazy with anger and frustration because
of little space to
actually move around freely and when you
look at all those factors you see
you know the ingredients list that
creates the crazy and most of those
ingredients are made
in urban environments in big cities
where people are squashed together with
their energies
and they're all affecting each other one
by one by one in this huge cycle so
so i think you know that's my list
that's what i think really contributes
to the mental health crisis which is
increasing dramatically
what do you guys think is a part of that
so i think those are all fantastic
points and
i have two different um ideas i want to
sort of
move off on here so first of all what
you're describing with these general
mental health issues people who are
actually diagnosed
over the past 70 years and i would say
that this really occurred probably
maybe most prominently in the 1970s you
have this fucoin de-institutionalization
movement
so today there are fewer people not even
adjusting for population size
in mental institutions than there were
in the 1970s we just don't commit people
anymore
so i think that's one huge part of the
problem but i want to speak even more
broadly just about people not being able
to recognize reality i think those are
all fantastic reasons why someone would
develop a
serious pathology but i'm going to stick
to
what i was saying earlier and i think it
also pretty lines up pretty well with
what you're saying that people
have been conditioned by a society with
no interest in promoting virtue to
always take the path of least resistance
and the path of least resistance does
not get you to the truth and the ability
to be
sane is simply to see the world for what
it is the less truthful your
understanding of the world is the
crazier you are
and so two plus two equals five exactly
and if i am told two plus two equals
five
and i'm in a room and i don't know if
the people in the room agree with me or
disagree with me
i am more or less likely to stand up and
advocate for the truth depending upon
how often i say no to myself
and do things that are uncomfortable and
if i'm not comfortable enough to stick
up for the truth i'm going to stop
believing in it and that's a fact
because
can't take credit for this i don't
remember which bishop said this but you
either live what you believe or you
believe what you live
amen it feels like we're adrift in a
sailboat
you know the conservatives want to pull
the sail
and they can't control the wind but they
can direct their sails and guide us to a
specific location
and the left just wants to drop the sail
sit back and just say oh
when you look at modern leftism i think
they want to tear the ship apart
yeah yeah absolutely they don't like the
ship is is uh
uh the people on the ship are eating the
fish as they go it's not fair
the ship is making principles that said
two plus two they're drinking the salt
water bro
yeah yeah they're drinking the salt
water i don't have any lemons we keep
telling them not to do it and they've
lost it already though
dehydrated and they're going insane i
wonder um but i i think
you know looking at the zach goldberg
data what you see is
there's a question does being in the
left
make you mentally ill or does the left
just attract the mentally ill
it's a vicious cycle i think the left
attracts people who can't see the world
very clearly for what it is and
sometimes it takes advantage of people
who are very well-meaning
want to help those beneath them and have
been lied to and convinced that the only
way to help those beneath them is to
bind a left-wing ideology
but once you're in it the way they
deconstruct the world as it exists with
their nominalist philosophy which
essentially posits that
everything in the world is essentially
meaningless and only humans put labels
on things then you can move anything
around in whatever direction you want so
that it suits your particular fancies
instead of having to contend with
reality for what it is to shorten what
you said
is being in a city makes you mentally
ill which makes you a statement yes
is that correct i think there's a lot of
truth in that yeah that's certainly what
i'm
articulating i'll put it this way when
we talk about jonathan the moral
moral foundations research conservatives
have all six moral foundations
fairly evil evenly distributed that
seems fairly well-rounded
uh liberals only have care and fairness
they disregard risk everything else and
libertarians
have none but liberty it's really it's
really my favorite it's like
i guess in their research they were they
were like getting to a point where
someone had no moral foundations they
were confused
and then they realized they were missing
one of the foundations liberty and so
they also understand that mental health
is an inside job that no one else is
going to be responsible for their mental
health but then themselves and people
need to
work at it every single day like mental
health is not something that's
guaranteed to you there's a lot of
things
literally vying to make you unstable to
make you crazy
there's so many foods that brought that
alter your brain chemistry
pornography alters your brain chemistry
in so many negative ways as well
uh there's so many negative aspects that
are attacking your consciousness
that it's truly almost a job that you
have to do
as much as you can to fight for your
mental sanity and health in this larger
sick society
that's being perpetrated by a lot of
these multinational corporations that
are thriving and benefiting off of it
amen
you don't remind me of well go ahead i
just want to jump on top of what you
just said it was interesting to me how
you mentioned pornography right after
mentioning food
because this has been a connection
theologians have made including the
great thomas aquinas that people's
inability to control their appetite with
respect to food
often um often results in them being
unable to control their sexual appetites
and we see that the pursuit of pleasure
in these ways particularly
makes people a lot less reasonable and
it makes sense because
your sexuality is the part of yourself
that really interacts with others in the
most productive possible way it's what
you create human beings with and it's
also one of the most intimate parts
about yourself
and people who want to claim that your
sexuality isn't intimate and that this
is a puritanical view
will out themselves when you question
their sexual lifestyle choices and they
freak out at you because they know it is
intimate they know it is personal and so
when people make the most intimate
personal part of themselves directed
specifically towards pleasure rather
than the good rather than doing what's
reasonable
all of their other actions follow suit
short term versus long term
this reminds me of you know why women in
brazil have big butts
i what why is that you know that like
right right luke you know that brazilian
women have big booties
yes many trips to brazil
i had a lot of fun you didn't know that
i've never heard this before
yeah uh so it's true women in brazil
tend to have very very big butts you
know why
because they live on the top of hills in
the favelas
so the women when they're going home
they have to climb up hills and their
legs and butts get really
strong and their upper bodies are remain
small because you don't use your arms to
walk up a hill and i remember i had a
friend in brazil who was telling me how
they were installing cable cars
so that they could help modernize the
favelas and he was like man they're
putting our
our most prominent export at risk but
anyway
no i bring this up because the the the
shape of the terrain
created something specific to the
culture of brazil and so when you're
talking about how your mind is shaped
you i think about it this way imagine if
you knew somebody who only worked out
their left forearm not their not their
biceps just the forearm it was the only
thing they
worked out and then one day you see them
and they have this
massive like massive left forearm and
you're like
uh what about the rest of you like you
think they had cancer or something
you'd be like your arm is really swollen
oh it's muscle and you're like but
nowhere else on your body
what i mean is your brain is very much
the same way
but it can be developed in an infinite
number of ways your muscles can grow can
shrink you can strengthen them you can
you can you know tune them up you can do
aerobic anaerobic you can increase
stamina or strength but your brain can
develop in a bunch of different ways
so if you're exercising the same thing
over and over and over again in your
brain or a society's terrain
is driving you towards mental illness
you are strengthening the mental illness
every day
you engage in that behavior yes another
example of this is that you're a
representation of the five closest
people you always hang out with or
you know in more layman's terms you
become who you're around
if you're in new york city and you're a
bunch around a whole bunch of crazy
schizophrenic insane people
you're going to slowly be affected by
that energetically
at least on some micro level and and
literally it leads you to
a trail that that eventually leads you
there if you're around it long enough
yeah exactly i mean when you're
surrounded by people who are always
going to validate you and your choices
instead of challenging you to grow of
course you're going to devolve into very
serious mental illness or at least a
deep inability to see the world for what
it is
this is what happens when you take a
handful of people let's say take five
people
and there's no clear leader what will
happen is they'll all follow each other
it creates a whirlpool effect where they
one-up each other over and over and over
again
where one person says something dumb the
other person validates it the next
person validates them
and then and they keep doing that and
then what happens is you can think of it
mathematically the first person yells
out one
the next person yells out two the next
person has a three and then it keeps
going around until they're in the
millions right yeah
but that that works with like hatred
someone the first person says
man i don't like donald trump the next
person says yeah trump is the worst
the next person says trump is like worse
than like way worse than anybody else
then someone says yeah trump is worse
than hitler and it just keeps going
that's what the media has been doing
there's no leader to stop and say dude
shut up
and stop the cycle and just shut it down
yeah absolutely and then people lose
their minds thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you